welcome back to PE Morgan on sensor sax
gate was the Scandal that made Russell
Brand notorious Geor Georgina Bailey the
granddaughter of FY Tower star Andrew
saxs was in a relationship with Brown
when she was 20 and he was 30 Brown was
fired after he and his BBC Radio 2
co-host Jonathan Ross left vulgar
messages on Andrew Sax's voicemail
bragging that brand had slept with his
granddaughter look Andrew saxs I've got
respect for you and your lineage and
progeny never let that be questioned I
was hinting why did that come across as
a hint because you know what you're that
wasn't a hint now when you were doing a
[Laughter]
granddaughter Andrew sax I did not do
nothing with Georgina oh no I've
revealed I know a name oh no it's a
disaster well the BBC received more than
40,000 complaints radio 2's controller
quit over the Scandal and brown was
fired I'm joined in the studio now by
Andrew Sax's granddaughter Georgina
Bailey Georgina I can see almost
coiling in horror listening to that
again because it was I remember
listening to that and thinking a I
thought it was disgusting and B I
couldn't believe that it had been edited
and put out it wasn't live this would
been taped and then put out by the BBC
exactly was it live for you to be caught
in that storm well it wasn't pleasant um
I was very young at the time I was 23
years old when the story broke and it
was a very unnerving time because not
only have my grand Grand parents heard
about what I've been up to sexually
which anybody would recoil at um but
then it's all the boys will be boys
attitude and like oh isn't it funny
she's only she's a anyway so like who
cares um so that was their only line of
defense is to sort of shame me
basically obviously their behavior was
appalling and everyone agreed with that
how did Russell treat you when you were
actually in a relationship well first of
all I I don't I wouldn't consider me and
Russell having been in a relationship we
had like a sort of Friends with Benefits
type situation which was fine in my
early 20s um and he was always very nice
to me like he it was very clear what the
parameters of the relationship were um
and that was mutually agreed upon and um
never did anything onto happen and he
later right and obviously that came and
that was shocking but later uh a few
years later he did actually help paid
you to go through rehab yes exactly so
um I was struggling with addiction for
about 10 15 years and um I I was finding
it very hard to get clean and sober so
um one of my mutual friends between me
and Russell called him up and said you
know George you need some help and so he
sent me to rehab and I I was physically
separated from my drug of choice and I
got some therapy and I think that had a
big part to play in my my recovery
Journey um and he looked me in the eyes
and he made his amends to me which is
what we do in recovery we have to make
amends to people what did he say to you
he just acknowledged that it was a
private relationship and it shouldn't
have been made public and that at the
time he had two daughters and I think
that it really made him grow and change
and um yeah he he he I felt it was
genuine I felt that he was sorry so we
cut for this was 2018 so we cut forward
five years now he's all over the front
pages of every paper as an alleged
rapist and sexual abuser what was your
reaction when you first heard about this
um so initially first of all I have been
a survivor of sexual abuse okay and I
will always believe victims because why
wouldn't you would you always believe
accusers accusers it it it depends I
wasn't in the room you know we weren't
in the room we don't know what happened
there um
but my initial thought was oh my God I'm
glad I'm not Russell because it's it's
it's behavior that he was doing when he
wasn't well so when you're an addict you
can cross addict so if you're not
working a program he explained this to
me when he made his amends you can be
off booze and drugs but if you're not
working a program you can be acting out
on a sex addiction or a food addiction
and he wasn't working a program and as
an addict in
I know that he wasn't well so I have to
that doesn't justify rape and sexual
assault it really it does not if indeed
that is what he did I mean I've read
I've only read what I've read I've seen
the dispatch's program they are
disturbing allegations but they are
allegations do you I mean do you
recognize the person described in these
reports no I don't but I'm not saying
that they're lies because um you know it
was a long time ago we all and I think
they should be believed um and get some
help because part of the recovery
program is you must make amends for
these things and that's what he did to
me and hopefully he'll do the same for
the others but you're presuming he's
guilty
I'm and I wouldn't say that I would say
that I'm I'm taking it in with a pinch
of salt maybe for want of a better would
it not be better now if this becomes a
police investigation to try and
determine whether these allegations are
in fact of course legally s of course
yeah have you spoken to Russell about
any of this no I haven't um do you want
to call him you feel that way or do you
want to keep out of it um to be honest
you know all all I've got is my own
truth
and yeah I I don't I don't know what I
would say to him really I mean it's an
odd Journey you've been with him he sort
of ruined well you had a nice time with
him then he sort of ruined your life for
a bit then he saved your life
potentially by helping you with the
rehab it's been quite a journey between
the two yeah it's what are what are your
feelings towards him today well I feel
like he was a different person during
those times he was young and stupid and
as was I and um things would have been
done differently now I think um
shaming was totally fine back then and
uh so I was an easy target but um sorry
what was the question well just just
what your thought your thoughts towards
him are right now I I want him to
continue on his path of recovery and
when he makes a mistake make an amends
that's what we do at the moment he's
categorically deny these allegations I
hear
that yeah when you read when you read
the reports you think there may be Merit
to what these girls are saying these
women are saying I from my own personal
experience do not see Russell as a
rapist um however a lot of the the
evidence is very compelling
so one has to keep an open
mind what are you doing now with your
life oh that's a big question yeah um so
I'm an artist I paint mainly um and I do
big commissions for people and I also
I'm an actress and I had the lead role
in a play last year two years ago and
also I have a little TV series called
Fanny business in which I play a 50s
housewife who's a bit
insane and you you hope you don't mind
me saying you said you've been clean now
for a number of years I've been clean
and sober for three and a three and a
half years I'll be turning four on
February 16th so you're in a good place
I would say so yeah I'm glad to hear
that because I think what you went
through in that sax Gate scandal was
yeah it was bit rubbish I thought it was
just a terrible way to treat a young
woman uh really was and very
unacceptable so I'm glad to see you
doing well best of luck to you thank you
very much thank you good to see
you